low-level prog charts are something you
need to be familiar with as a pilot not
only will you get asked about these on
your written exam but you should also be
able to read them so you can avoid bad
weather and for my private pilot
students these are going to help us
determine if we're going to be able to
fly vfr before we break down these
charts i want you to take note of what
these charts are called prog charts that
stands for prognostic to prognosticate
means to tell the future and that's
important to keep in mind because these
are weather forecasts not current
observations and with that in mind let's
talk about deciphering these things and
don't worry these things are really easy
to read now there are a ton of different
places you can get these charts but i'm
going to show you how to get them from
your official weather source which is
aviationweather.gov
let's go up here to forecast then scroll
down to prog charts and take a quick
look in here now since this video is
specifically for private pilots let's
scroll down here to the low level prog
charts and the surface plots first we'll
take a look at this low level plot and
as you probably noticed this forecast
tells us the forecast from the surface
to 24 000 feet i'll go ahead and click
here and we'll take a quick look before
we talk about this notice here that this
chart is specifically displaying what
the national weather service believes to
be significant weather
look down here at the legend and you'll
see what that significant weather is
now notice this note right here it says
for flight planning only see tafts for
specific terminal forecasts tafts are
your official weather forecast these
charts just give you a general picture
of where the hazardous weather is going
to be we'll get to that in just a second
but notice at the bottom left of each of
these images there's some data down here
this chart on the left is a forecast of
the next 12 hours and the chart on the
right is a forecast of the next 24 hours
above that you'll see a little vt here
with a zulu time this stands for valid
through so this chart is valid through
1800 zulu on 28 april and this one is
valid until zero 600 zulu on 29 april if
we click up here on this time tab we can
change this if we need to make sure we
have the most current forecast let's
look down at these symbols and see what
they mean
solid red lines surrounding areas like
this indicate the ceilings in these
areas will be less than a thousand feet
and or the visibility is going to be
less than three statute miles so why do
i care about that you probably already
know the answer to this but these are
the basic vfr minimums so these are
going to be ifr areas now this puffy
blue cloud indicates ceilings between
one and three thousand feet and or
visibility between three and five
statute miles this is what we call
marginal vfr because whether or not you
can legally take off vfr depends on the
airspace you're in and what that
specific field is reporting now orange
dash lines like this indicate moderate
or greater turbulence in these areas now
notice this little symbol that looks
like a little mountain this indicates
what altitude you can expect the
turbulence just like on most aviation
weather charts to get the altitude you
simply add two zeros so up here the
turbulence starts at twenty four
thousand feet and goes down to twenty
thousand feet
a lot of times if there's any confusion
on where the turbulent symbol goes
they'll draw an arrow so you don't get
confused so i know these altitudes are
for this area over here and this one
goes down here
okay so you probably notice that this
one doesn't have an altitude on one side
if you see this this just means that the
turbulence goes down to the surface now
we have this dash cyan line
this tells us where the freezing level
is in msl down here in georgia you can
see that the freezing level is at 12 000
feet msl
up in north dakota you can see it's at 8
000 feet msl now there aren't any here
on this chart but if you ever see this
cyan zigzag line the freezing level is
at the surface in these areas right now
you're probably wondering why you care
about this this isn't quite as important
for vfr pilots but for ifr pilots it's
extremely important if you're above the
freezing level and you fly through any
moisture whatsoever like a cloud you'll
have a really high chance of picking up
icing and as you know vfr pilots
shouldn't be flying through clouds so
this isn't quite as big a deal to them
now on the written exam you'll likely
get asked a couple questions about prog
charts and unfortunately on the test the
charts look a little different than the
real ones and the colors are slightly
off but it still should be fairly simple
because they give you a legend and
that's going to make it a lot easier the
big thing to remember though is to pay
attention to the question and make sure
you choose the appropriate chart because
remember you have a 12-hour forecast and
a 24-hour forecast okay i want to show
you just a couple more things let's go
back to forecast then prog charts and
take a quick look down here at the
bottom at the surface plot which once
again is a forecast not a current
observation
make sure you choose the appropriate
time you need and once you do this can
give you an awesome view of the weather
you can expect just like the other
charts down here at the bottom there's a
key that tells you what a lot of these
symbols mean in my video on weather
basics i explain all of these in detail
and the weather you can expect from each
you definitely want to watch that if you
haven't already actually i may not have
explained these troughs though and you
might find that useful
these are elongated areas of low
pressure and as you can see most of
these extend out of the low pressure
areas now if you remember what a front
is it's basically a large area of either
low pressure or high pressure that can
push its way into other areas so it is
possible for these to turn into fronts
with that in mind you may remember that
low pressure areas like these troughs
are usually associated with bad weather
and that's because that lighter low air
pressure is being lifted and that
lifting motion can cause the air to be
less stable and as i mentioned in that
other video the weather you get depends
on two things how much moisture is in
the air and the temperature remember
water vapor is lighter than air so the
more that there is the more quickly that
air rises and the hotter it is the
faster it rises as well because the air
is less dense so during the summer it's
not uncommon to see isolated
thunderstorms in these areas the
national weather service has upgraded
these charts a lot in the last few years
because now instead of putting a bunch
of crazy symbols and stuff on these
charts they've color coded these to make
it a lot easier and these colors give
you a really good picture of the type of
precipitation you can expect now i'm not
going to insult your intelligence by
walking you through these but as you can
tell this is a great way to keep an eye
out for thunderstorms and determine the
type of precipitation you can expect i
hope you found today's video helpful if
you did be sure to check this video out
next when you go to take that private
palette check ride you'll be glad you
did
[Music]